so then they tell you you got to join
the me2 movement you got to join the
LGBTQ movement you got to join the
transgender identity movement and so
what happens to the church is it chases
the world until it abandons its own
message we are here on the Sunday
special with the great John MacArthur
who is the president of the Masters
University and we're gonna get into an
enormous amount of his philosophy and
work we're gonna get into religion and
freewill and pollux so many good things
but first let's talk about your sleep
quality there's no one on the planet
quite like you so why would you buy a
generic mattress built for anyone else
helix sleep built to sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete they use
your answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper a
hot sleeper whether you like a plush or
firm bed with helix there's no more
guessing and no more confusion just go
to helix sleep calm slash bend guests
take their two minutes sleep quiz and
they will match you to a mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life four couples helix can even split
that mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've a ten
year warranty get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free so you really have
nothing to lose right now helix is
offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders get up to 125 bucks off
at helix sleep comm slash been guest
because I have a guest that is hulex
sleep calm slash been guest for 125
bucks off your mattress order I promise
you the mattresses really are
comfortable I'm not fibbing about it my
wife and I have one we wouldn't talk
about it otherwise we got it in the mail
inflates right in front you when you
open the box you toss it on the bed
frame you're good to go it's so good I
got one for my sister for her wedding as
well go check it out right now
helix sleep calm slash men gasp that's
helix sleep calm slash of n guests well
mr. MacArthur customer Carter thank you
so much for showing up here I know that
we had more anticipation in the office
then we have had for I think virtually
any other guests that we've ever had on
the Sunday special that's amazing man
but I'm honored to be here well I'm
honored to have you so let's jump right
into the the issue of the day and that
is religion and politics so you're not
known as an overtly political preacher
you talk more about values than politics
what do you think the relationship
should be between folks who are in the
business of religion and trying to
inform people about religion and
politics how often should they be
speaking about politics should they be
doing so openly or
or just preaching values my calling my
mandate the command from heaven to me is
to preach the gospel to the ends of the
earth that's the message that I am
committed and mandated by God to preach
it's the gospel politics is is the art
of reordering human society on a
temporal basis the message of the gospel
has to do with eternal eternal issues
that doesn't mean I avoid everything
political because I also want to do
anything I can to elevate justice and
righteousness in the world and so as a
Christian I want to take responsibility
for whatever political avenues that I
can go down that are going to increase
the order of society the blessing of
society I want to be pro-family pro-life
Pro Tarek tur Pro virtue Pro morality
all those kinds of things Pro honesty
Pro kindness Pro mercy Pro grace all of
those things in my culture that that's
mandated to me as well
I am too I'm to be a citizen who submits
to the powers that be I am NOT to be a
revolutionary we don't start riots
that's not a Christian thing to do we
don't even start revolutions and you
could argue about the American
Revolution whether that was actually
legitimately a Christian act or not we
don't start revolutions we submit to the
powers that be and we work to change the
culture from the inside one soul at a
time okay so let's talk about that for a
second in terms of the leadership that
we picked so obviously you're talking a
lot about submitting to the temporal
nature of government if you go back to
the Old Testament it was prophets who
are anointing Kings what should our role
be in a democracy in terms of shaping
the values of that democracy for
political reasons you see a lot of
pastors who endorse particular political
candidates do you think that that's
worthwhile and especially because a lot
of the issues that you talked about are
inherently political they may not have
been political 50 years ago but when you
say pro-life pro-family Pro religion
these actually do have real-world
consequences in the world of policy that
was a little different 50 years ago when
we might have been talking about some
sort of social structure and economics
we're not talking about that anymore
we're talking about morality now we're
talking about whether we kill babies or
don't kill babies we're talking about
what is marriage we're talking about
what is a family what what is male what
is
email that that those are the issues now
that have made their way into the
political world so that it's fraught
with moral issues and if you are one who
has a moral authority which would be the
word of the Living God the Creator then
your responsibility in any society is to
make sure that God's moral standards are
heard I can't force people to take those
things but when it comes for example a
second Samuel talks about rulers are to
be just and to fear God and not take
bribes I mean that is what the Old
Testament says so that means if I'm
looking at a politician who has a
history of being bribed who has no fear
of God who is atheistic or practical
atheistic that's not a divine
qualification that I can support
somebody for example who advocates the
slaughter of babies which is murder by
by any biblical definition any moral
definition that is not a just ruler that
is not a man of mercy when Moses was
selecting the rulers who would come
under him in the book of Exodus the
qualifications were very very clear they
had to be just and they had to be moral
and they had to fear God so as much as I
can as a Christian that's the kind of
leader that I want to see that's the
direction I want to see a society go for
temporarily the benefit of that society
the immediate benefit of that society
ordered families are a tremendous common
grace obedient children are a common
grace an ordered culture where people
submit to the authorities as it talks
about in in in the New Testament the
powers would be ordained of God God has
ordained structure so I want to vote for
the structures that produce the most
ordered society and so how do we
distinguish in leadership terms
obviously we have a serious problem as
religious people I had a big problem
personally in 2016 because the
representative of the party to which I
am an adherent typically and I voted
straight line Republican as long as I
can remember the the leader of that
party was somebody who well he stood for
some of my values and has turned out to
stand for many more of my values than I
thought he would in 2016
that on a personal level he doesn't
fulfill certain basic moral precepts
about character about the necessity of
cleanliness and business dealings about
the the decency with regard to women for
example as religious people how should
we approach issues like that about how
to choose between candidates who may not
be personally moral but maybe for word
our priorities and disengage completely
what should what do you think the
solution yeah I mean it's it's a
challenging reality it's less
challenging today than it used to be
because again you have a party that
advocates the killing of babies I can't
vote that I don't care who the other guy
is you're looking in some ways that the
lesser of two evils but you always are
in society anyway because nobody is
perfect so what I'm looking for in a
leader and it may come down to a simple
analogy if I'm going to have a brain
surgeon opening my brain I'm really not
too concerned about his moral life I
would like to know that he's been in
somebody else's brain and done the right
thing whenever he's been there and he
knows his way around there's a certain
skillset for leadership there's a
certain ability that people need to
affect change
and if you have a guy who manifests the
ability to do that the presidency is not
a moral job it's not a position of moral
authority it never has been we don't
want to make it into that now you choose
the best you've got which would be
someone who does justice fears God that
is to say there's a transcendental ought
that binds his heart an atheist doesn't
have that even the founders of America
who were not Christians they were deists
knew God had to be in there somewhere
because there had to be some kind of
existential power that had exerted the
threat over people that they misbehaved
so you're looking for that in a
president then you're looking for
competence and competence is really
defined in my judgment at that level as
leadership ability so who has the
leadership ability who can move things
in the right direction and who's closest
to a biblical moral standard without
expecting that he would be faithful to
that fully who's closest to it so it
sounds like you think that as a society
we've made a pretty
mistake in trying to see the president
as a moral figure anyway meaning there's
been a lot of talk that the presidency
is basically two jobs one is
implementing policy making sure certain
things happen and the other is as sort
of a moral leader of the country
creating a sense of social fabric in the
country
and on one of those scores the current
president has been good on policy he
hasn't been very good at putting
together social fabric from my point of
view but it maybe it sounds like what
you're saying is that what we ought to
be doing is stop looking to the
presidency at all as the builder of the
social fabric in other words it's our
job in our communities to build a social
fabric let the president do what the
president needs to do policy wise yeah
and look you can't blame him for the
complete destruction of the family he
had nothing to do with that that's why
the fabrics coming apart you know when
you think about how God looks at this or
any Society the default position of
humanity is brutally corrupt I mean you
read the the blood lands so between
Soviet Russia and Germany between the
late 1930s and 45 13 million people are
killed none in a military uniform none
in a war 13 million people were
massacred by Russians and Germans in in
those brief years that is a testimony to
what will happen to people when evil is
not restrained evil is restrained God is
designed evil to be restrained three
ways number one is conscience and
everybody has a mechanism it's a
skylight that reacts the Bible says to
accuse or excuse you but conscience only
works if you have a defined belief
system the guys that 911 guys blew up a
building that worked in their conscience
because they had a faulty belief system
so you can tamper with conscience when
you alter belief when you tamper with
truth or when you eliminate truth the
conscience is lost the second mechanism
God put in society to govern and
constrain is parents and the Old
Testament is so clear that's the one
commandment with a promise children obey
your parents for this is right and it'll
go well with you and you'll be
successful
and the way to destroy that mechanism is
just to tear the family to shreds
redefine it abuse men turn men into some
kind of joke that dispossessed them of
all moral authority there's only one
other mechanism God has put into place
to restrain evil and that is the
government the government is - according
to the New Testament honor the good and
punish the evildoer and the Bible even
says they don't bear a sword for nothing
they even have the power of capital
punishment which was instituted back in
Genesis so if you attacked the
conscience by destroying the belief
system if you attack the family by
destroying the roles there and then the
next step you're gonna face you attack
all authority you just do anything you
can to just strip Authority of its power
and its honor you literally have
decimated a culture then you take a guy
in stick him in a presidential role you
think he's going to restore moral
authority in a culture that's an
impossible task so when we talk about
restoring moral authority in the culture
it seems like there are a couple of ways
that have been pursued with regard
particularly to young people and one is
a biblical path and one is for lack of a
better term the utilitarian
judeo-christian path the biblical path
would be get people back in churches
tell them about the veracity of the
Bible in you in your view the New
Testament might be the Old Testament in
and then train them basically step by
step believe in God believe in the Bible
believe in biblical values enact those
values in your own life build social
fabric around that the other way is I
think tailored more to a secular
audience which is take the same messages
of the Bible without actually mentioning
biblical text and use those values and
say that these values work these are the
values that have worked these are the
values that build civilization these
values are useful and that's why you
should bear them out do you think that
one is preferable to the other - they
are they both useful these two paths and
which audiences should we tailor to
because the other reason I ask is
because what I found is that as a north
I never cite the Bible in any of my
lectures and the reason I do is because
most of the people I'm talking to you
don't have that common frame of
reference and what I find is that I get
a lot of emails from people then saying
that they've started to reengage with
biblical thinking not because I've cited
the Bible but simply because they've
heard the values I'm talking about now
are interested in those values but
that's only one way of coming at it
another way is to actually inculcate
people in the reality of the religion
itself which no one do you think is
preferable and when are these useful I
think both of them could be useful I
think that the biblical approach is
preferable by a long shot because again
you're taking the authority to an
existential level you're moving the
authority up to its highest level if I
tell people that they ought to do this
because it's reasonable to do this and
it's historically the way it works if
they can show me in history where it
didn't work they can go back to the
blood lens and show it didn't work then
it didn't work when they when they
killed six million Jews in the Holocaust
it didn't it doesn't work the Lord of
the Flies is there's a default position
of human behavior I don't like to be
caught in the trap of trying to make
history authoritative because there are
too many exceptions to that we've got
the best of it in a sense in Western
civilization doesn't really look so good
if you if you go some other direction
like Africa or something like that or
even the Middle East I need something
that is a rock solid immovable
unchanging and absolute authority I
really don't have I don't have enough
power I don't have enough verbal power
or enough persuasive convicting speech
in me to convince people to live a
certain way I'm not ever going to be
anybody's moral authority but if I say
what the Old Testament prophet said the
word of the Lord came unto me the word
of the Lord came unto me now I
understand that I have a divine
authority I don't ever want to speak
without referring to the Bible and I
don't I don't want to apologize for that
because it's a secular culture and they
don't like it I I really feel badly that
they don't like that but if they don't
ever
connect with that there they're lost
that they're lost both in life and
eternity I have to connect them to the
Word of God okay so in just a second I
want to ask you about how that view
meshes with sort of the Enlightenment
values that are enshrined in the
Constitution Declaration of Independence
but first let's talk about what happens
when you die don't talk about what
happens after you die I mean like when
you actually plots your family's gonna
need to bury you and they're gonna need
money to do that and that's why it would
been good if you'd gotten life insurance
you should have thought of that before
shouldn't you well here's the good news
you're alive listening to the sad so
you're thinking of it right now and the
reason you're thinking of it right now
is cuz I'm talking to you about policy
genius policy genius ensures that you
have life insurance it's a very good
feeling to have life insurance you won't
have to start to GoFundMe to stay afloat
it's the easy way to get life insurance
online in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find the best policy for you and when
you compare quotes you save money it is
indeed that simple policy genius has
helped over 4 million people shop for
the insurance and placed over twenty
billion dollars in coverage they don't
just do life insurance they do
disability insurance auto insurance home
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so if you've been avoiding
getting life insurance because it's
difficult or confusing give policy
genius a try just go to policy genius
com get your quotes apply in minutes you
can do the whole thing on your phone
right this very instant policy genius is
the indeed the easy way to compare and
buy life insurance don't plots without
it go check it out policy genius the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance well let's let's get back to
the the sort of meshing of biblical
values with American values so early on
you mentioned that you weren't sure that
the American Revolution is is in
consonance with biblical values I was
wonder if you could expound on that a
little bit I think it's an interesting
idea well the scripture says submit to
the powers that be that there are Dana
God that does not mean that every ruler
represents God clearly that is not the
case but that governmental authority is
a god-given institution to repress evil
and to reward good behavior just as
parents have that role in the conscience
as that role we've talked about so when
I when I talk about the government I'm
not saying that the government is a
divine authority or that the rulers are
divine authorities but what I am saying
is that they
represent a god-given constraint to
human behavior and that's why they have
to be upheld and not broken down so
Christians don't attack the government
we don't protest we don't riot we don't
start shooting people who are in the
government even if the government is
King George from England and we don't
like him and even if we're upset with
taxation we don't start riots and we
don't start revolutions we live quiet
according to the New Testament peaceable
lives we pray for those that are over us
we pray for rulers we pray for all those
who are in authority and we pray that
they might come to know God through the
savior of the Lord Jesus Christ so we
pray regularly for our rulers we do not
overthrow them and that is how a
Christian a real biblical Christian
would look at the at the American
Revolution I mean I hate to say that
because that's not a popular idea but it
is nonetheless what the scripture says
Christians are to do submit pray pray
for the salvation of your leaders live a
quiet and peaceable life and let the the
character of your life the godliness the
virtue of your life affect that society
one soul at a time so what does that
mean for individual rights because
obviously the American Revolution is
based on the idea that we are
individuals with certain rights that are
inherent in us I think that has history
going all the way back to Genesis
talking about us being made in God's
image with certain creative faculties
and that comes along with the ability to
think for ourselves the ability to
worship God the ability to build these
families the founding ideology is based
around the idea that if the government
itself was a threat to your fundamental
rights including as a religious person
then the government had lost its
legitimacy is there a point in in your
philosophy in theology where the
government loses its legitimacy it's the
Soviet Union they're cracking down on
churches it's Nazi Germany right is that
is there a point where a revolution
would be justifiable or necessary not
not in a biblical sense no I don't think
there's ever a time when you would be
justified in starting to kill the people
that are in power I don't I don't see
any justification for that that is not
what Christians do we would rather
suffer but but I don't want to say we
don't descend because we do
and one of the things that comes up in
this is freedom of speech dude is
freedom of speech a biblical right it's
not really an issue in the Bible freedom
of speech speech is controlled we're to
speak kindly we're to speak with grace
we're to speak what edifies and builds
up and encourages and comforts we're not
to lie we're not to curse
we're not the blaspheme so speech is
controlled in in in the categories of
righteousness and as opposed to sinful
speech so we don't have complete freedom
of speech we are also in the New
Testament told to speak what edifies but
we also are commanded necessarily to
dissent in our speech when the
government is asking us to do something
that is wrong or that God is telling us
to do one thing they're telling us to do
something else
illustration in the New Testament the
Apostles go out and they preach Christ
and the Jews arrest them and say stop
and so they said you judge whether we
obey God or men and they went right back
out to preach Christ for freedom of
speech for us is freedom to preach the
truth of Christ even when the society
says that's against the law and then you
don't get an army you go to jail they
went to jail they took the consequences
they suffered the consequences of the
faithfulness they had to preaching the
truth so we we do descended Christians
have always descended through history
they've always had a dissenting message
when persecution came and inevitably
just to generalize that a little bit
when persecution of free speech comes it
always comes against the people who have
the religious absolutes always because
that's what threatens people's freedom
to sin so we're always going to be the
culprits at that point we become
dissenters because we continue to preach
the truth no matter what the price so my
question with regards to sort of your
vision of government is that on the one
hand it seems as though in a utopian
world there would be a biblically based
government that is the ekran akin nature
and that is scary to a lot of folks who
are enlightenment fans it's scary to me
frankly I mean I'm not a big fan of
theocracy even as an Orthodox Jew
at the same time the the it could lead
to the possibility of as I say a
tyrannical government that we can't do
anything about except I guess complain
so how do we how do we live that life I
mean are you advocating the for a
theocracy an utopian world would that be
a good thing that was that was what
Israel was supposed to be a theocracy
right I mean the the the people who ran
the government were priests essentially
the orders of the priests they were the
officials of the government that was a
theocratic Kingdom and God was king
there was a very very deep-seated
difficulty in pulling that off and we
know the history of that because of
disobedience because of rejection of God
God had even punished the people he
loved you know with captivity the the
northern king goes into the Assyrian
captivity the southern game goes to
Babylon you have the history of the Old
Testament it's a sad history of
punishment and yet God continues to
extend grace to to Israel and still does
to this very day so there's not going to
be even though it would be God God would
want a theocratic Kingdom with him as
king and everybody's subjected to him
that doesn't work in this world and
that's why he had to send a savior the
New Testament teaches us this that there
will never be in a utopian Kingdom it's
impossible that there would be and
that's why you have to keep the
restraints in that God has placed there
you have to have absolute laws you have
to have absolute convictions absolute
precepts that moral precepts that you
believe because that's what makes your
conscience work you have to have ordered
families and you have to have authority
with the power to restrain evil and
reward good and as those break down it
just gets worse and worse in fact the
New Testament says evil men are going to
get worse and worse this is going to
continue to get worse New Testament says
in the future the Messiah will return
and establish his kingdom the kingdom he
promised really starting in Genesis 12
with Abraham the Kingdom he reiterated
to David that when the Messiah came the
greater son of David would establish his
kingdom forever the Kingdom he promised
to the prophets the kingdom he promised
with salvation to jeremiah and jeremiah
31 that he would put in in israel a new
heart and a new spirit and they would
walk after his laws and the New
Testament says the Messiah came the
first time to be the sacrifice for the
sins of his people the second time
becomes to establish that Kingdom so we
can't do that in this world with a
fallen humanity it's not possible the
Lord will do it in the future when he
returns to establish the kingdom on
earth and the New Testament teaches that
that's a real actual kingdom even Isaiah
defines the lion lying down with the
lamb and the desert blossomed like a
rose is a lot of elements that they're
physical as well as spiritual with all
the said how do you view the
Enlightenment right now there's a big
debate that's happening in in
conservative circles and but I think
it's crossed across ideological lines
with regards in the Enlightenment on the
one hand you have folks who basically
argued that the Enlightenment is a break
with religious tradition the religious
tradition is about submitting to a
governmental authority that may in fact
be pushing the certain theocratic ideals
and that the Enlightenment comes along
it tosses out the Bible it replaces it
with the deistic concept of God and
reason and that we get human rights
flourishing great economies iPhones all
sorts of cool things cuz we toss out the
Bible that's that sort of Sam Harris's
view Steven Pinker's view of the
Enlightenment and then there's and and I
think to a certain extent the view of
some thinkers who are who are not so Pro
might men who look at the downsides of
the enlightened people like Alastair
MacIntyre who look at the Enlightenment
they say well this kind of cleaned out
Western civilization of meaning at they
were sure we got iPhones we gave up
meaning in the trade and then there's
the other view of the Enlightenment
which is basically the Enlightenment is
in fact an outgrowth of 2,000 years of
Christian history and 3,000 years of
judeo-christian history as filtered
through historical circumstance and
changing religious sectarianism and that
without judeo-christianity there is no
enlightenment so there is no iPhone
without judeo-christianity the
Enlightenment was just sort of a
midpoint in that in that view so do you
see the Enlightenment as a break from
religion
did you see it as good do you see it as
bad I think you have to get the bigger
picture
when Christianity comes and the church
is founded the church flourishes in the
first century but by the time you get to
the third century and you get
Constantine you you have organizational
Christianity institutional Christianity
they decided that everybody's going to
be a Christian so they baptize all the
babies and everybody is a Christian and
you have essentially state-sponsored
Christianity that launches a thousand
years of the dark ages where religion
and relationship to God is not personal
the church is a surrogate it's a
surrogate for God and you connect to the
church you don't connect by faith you
don't connect in your heart by loving
the Lord or knowing him you connect by
mechanical means and all the fall over
all that made up that thousand years of
developing Christianity where wherever
there's a shortage of reality there's an
overabundance of symbol so they started
dressing like you know they were going
to a five-year-old club five year olds
birthday party as a clown and you have
this institutionalized kind of
Christianity that was dead cold and the
gospel was lost and truth was lost but
it had massive power over people and
what kept that power was don't put the
Bible in their language don't let him
read it the church is the only
interpreter of the Bible they can't
interpret scripture if anybody tried to
do the interpretation on their own they
would be murdered we know the story of
William Tyndale he translated the Bible
into English they chase him all over the
place till they finally kill him what
was his crime translating the Bible into
the language of the people so that every
quote plowboy in England could read the
scripture that is a crime that brings
down that kind of false system but it
led to the Reformation that what
happened in the Reformation was the
power of that institutionalized detached
surrogate God Church was broken and
Christianity went personal and the
gospel was preached to individuals and
and faith became the way you access
salvation personal faith in Christ and
his work that that
was the massive transformation sad to
say the Reformation might have turned
out differently if they hadn't decided
to take it and make it state churches
and then baptize all the babies into it
which is what they did but having said
that I think it's important to note that
in all those European countries for
example where the Reformation went you
have high levels of advancement they are
the leading edge of Western civilization
those countries that remain profoundly
Catholic were restrained in their
ability to develop on any level
educationally scientifically
industrially and we know that
historically it was the Protestant
countries that flourished they developed
the education they moved us forward
but inevitably you have the same problem
again because this is the default of
sinful humanity it wants to control and
it over extends its control so it wants
to make everybody a Christian get
everybody on board and eventually if
everybody's a Christian then really
nobody knows if anybody's a Christian
and that descends really fast into what
I see as the alight mint where people
didn't have a personal relationship with
God at all they only had another form of
an institutional relationship because
the Reformers never protected the
personal character of Christianity they
descended into the Enlightenment and I
see the Enlightenment as the abandonment
of judeo-christianity
and it was okay for a while because
there was still the vestiges of
believing in absolute truth and they
hung on to that but one or two
generations go by and if if they're like
the generation that knew not Joseph if
they don't know what the principles are
for that it all disappears and
disintegrates and and now we're at a
point in post-modernism where not only
do we not know what is absolute truth we
don't even believe there's such a thing
so I want to talk to you about that what
are the great threats to you know the
development of Western civilization
right now and why is it that if we have
this great biblical history and and this
possible connection with God that makes
our
it's richer and better and more profound
why everybody seems to have abandoned
that I want to talk to you about that in
just one second first let's talk about
how you can make your life better if
you're suffering right you actually need
to talk to somebody you need to talk to
somebody of our talk space it's an
online therapy company they let you
message a licensed therapist from
anywhere at any time all you need is a
computer with internet connection or the
talk space mobile app means you can
improve your mental health even if
you've had trouble making time for it in
the past now you know me I'm not a
touchy-feely dude but I can tell you
there are times when people are
depressed and there are times when
people need to talk to somebody and you
should talk to somebody if you're having
those sorts of feelings with talk space
therapy is as easy as sending your
therapist a message get something off
your chest whenever you need to talk
about everyday challenges at work or at
home you can chat about life
there are no extra commutes you don't
have to leave the office remember
therapy isn't just about venting your
innermost thoughts or digging into
childhood memories it's about practical
everyday strategies for stress
management that's the actual important
part and that helps you live a more
happy and easy life having a therapist
simply provides you a designated person
for you to talk to you outside ia's off
of come up with better strategies who's
trained to listen and help you make
those positive changes this talk space
platform has over 2,000 licensed
therapists who are experienced in
addressing life challenges everybody
faces to match her the perfect therapist
for a fraction of the price of
traditional therapy go to talk space.com
slash capiro use the promo code
Shapiro's to get 45 bucks off your first
month show support for this show that's
Shapiro talk space comm slash of Shapiro
go check it out right now so let's talk
a little bit about why it is that the
the church seems to have fallen away
pretty dramatically in the United States
so the United States was sort of the
last bulwark of Western religion we're
much more religious country than any of
the other European countries and church
attendance remained relatively high in
the United States up until the 1950s
it's been scheduled with steadily
declining religious adherence has been
steadily declining that phrase spiritual
not religious has been introduced into
the lexicon what do you think happened
with all that and do you see these sort
of spiritual but not religious movement
is a good thing like it's an indicator
that people are still looking for
something or is it just the last vestige
of people trying to graph something yeah
if you just take what you said about
spiritual but not religious which is
kind of a popular little mantra for
people today essentially what that means
is on my own god that's what they're
saying there's no authority outside me
I'm
spiritual I'm not religious which means
I don't subscribe to any transcendental
religion I don't just subscribe to any
higher authority I'm spiritual that just
means I'm kind of played my own navel
and I develop convictions about
spiritual reality from looking inside of
me which is the form of insanity really
to think that you can navigate the
realities of eternity and life and death
and life after death and the great
questions by looking into your own brain
is is pathetic it's sad but that's what
people are saying when they say I'm
spiritual I'm not religious that means I
don't look for spiritual reality
anywhere but in my own self that that is
that that is a formula for total
disaster because there has to be
external Authority there there must be
there must be God you cannot believe
that nobody times nothing equals
everything that's that's that's insane
there has to be a God he has to have
personality he has to be relational
because we are he has to be able to
reason and think he has to be able to
love and he has to be righteous and holy
and just as well as gracious and
merciful and kind because we see that
manifest he is the creator we swear in
His image we create you have to you have
to have God to get out of yourself and
find someone who can deliver you from
what you are and where you're headed
well I mean I certainly see and agree
with you that reason alone can't get you
morality it's one of the big debates
that I've been having with Sam Harris
repeatedly for the past couple of years
or Sam basically thinks that just by
reason alone we can get to a sort of
moral system Kant tried it he tried it
the best he failed everyone fails
because it turns out that the moral law
is not within in fact the moral law has
to come from someplace without what do
you think is the best proof to people
who don't believe of why there has to be
a god why should they take any of this
seriously and not just think okay it's a
compilation of various texts by various
old people over time why should they
take the Bible seriously in the first
place well I think the Bible is its own
defense
I've never defended the Bible I've just
preached it for almost 60 years I have
basically gone through the Bible verse
by verse by verse every single passage
from Genesis 1:1 to the final verse of
the book of
an Old Testament or New Testament and I
can I can only tell you that I have
never ever questioned the veracity and
the divine character of Scripture and
this is this is I'm talking about
in-depth study of every passage in the
Bible and I'm not the authority but I
can only tell you that under the most
the most intense scrutiny that my feeble
brain can bring to the Bible it stands
the test you can talk about defenses of
Scripture you can say well the Bible
predicts things that came to pass there
are Old Testament prophecies that came
to pass in the Old Testament like that
is the destruction of tyre and sidon and
those are recorded after they were
predicted and so you can look at that
you can look for example Hindu writings
say that the earth is on the back of
elephants who produce earthquakes when
they shake well that's ridiculous
the Bible says in Isaiah he hangs the
world on nothing he rules the earth like
clay to the seal which means it rotates
on an axis like you were rolling your
signature over soft clay that the
hydrological cycle is completely
explained in the Book of Isaiah there's
not foolishness other sacred writings
say that the the world is on layers of
honey and butter and cheese and crazy
things like that you can argue for a
fulfilled prophecy in the birth of Jesus
Christ that he would be born in
Bethlehem to be born of a virgin that
he'd be in a line of David and all of
that and that all comes to pass in the
genealogies are laid out in the new
tests so there there are things external
to the scripture that and not totally
external but you can look at the history
that is tied to Scripture but I think
the the power of Scripture is in the
scripture itself I think God God has a
glory all his own and he manifests that
in the Old Testament his glory is on
display we see that glory of God
throughout the history of the Old
Testament his glory comes to earth and
his son he is the glory of God
personified God has a glory also that
manifests itself in Scripture scripture
has in itself a glory a power that comes
through for someone who hasn't studied
it that sounds
and maybe a little mystical but what I'm
continually overwhelmed by is the
absolute truthfulness of Scripture and I
don't ever have to defend it I've been
doing this for a long time I've never
been in a position where I had to try to
explain something that was a legitimate
contradiction in the Bible so what do
you do with with these so-called
difficult sections of the Bible so the
case that to play devil's advocate for a
second and obviously it's it's
interesting to do this because you and I
agree about the veracity of at least the
first half of the Bible we have a
disagreement on where to file the site
of the New Testament you put in the
nonfiction section and I don't I'm
Jewish somebody but with that said the
the and we'll get to those disagreements
in just seconds I'd be remiss if we
didn't but to take the difficult
sections of Bible Sam Harris makes the
case that and I used to em but Richard
Dawkins does the same thing people who
sort of have a cursory glance at the
Bible read it once through on their
nightstand at a hotel and now our
experts and their I don't mean to be
dismissive but I do invite they by the
eye but the idea is that they will pick
out a section that is particularly
awkward and they will say okay well the
Bible was fine with this so what's the
deal let's do a couple of those sections
if you don't mind so let's take slavery
this is the the example that's very
often used that the Bible is okay with
slavery there are particular sections in
the Old Testament that specifically
talked about for example taking female
captives and then shaving their heads
and then marrying them for it forcing
them into marriage how do we square this
with the basic sense of Western morality
now which is that slavery is in a
terrible evil how could the Bible not
why didn't the Bible just abolish
slavery 3,000 years ago well first of
all the Bible would never condone taking
women as slaves shaving their heads and
turning them into some kind of abject
slavery that that's that would never be
advocated the the Old Testament elevates
women obviously so does the New
Testament but let's talk about slavery
the Bible never condones mistreating
anyone not even an animal the Bible
never condone mistreating anyone I want
to make that very clear the Bible calls
for love and kindness and support and
encouragement and protection and
provision one of the social constructs
in which that occurred in the purpose
of God was a form of slavery that the
word and the fact that slavery and being
a servant were so close this shows in
the word Abed which could mean both
which is to say that that the only
difference between being a servant who
showed up in the morning at nine o'clock
and left at 6:00 and being a slave was
you lived you had been purchased what
that meant was you had food you had
family you had protection
you had provision this was for many
people the most secure kind of
employment they could have ever hoped
for
with a good master with a faithful
master with a loving master and in the
New Testament fascinating the New
Testament word for slave is Doulos and
it's equivalent to FF in the Old
Testament but Doulos is the word for
slave and it is used dozens of times to
refer to a Christian when we confess
Jesus as Lord we are saying he is
curious lord I am Doulos his slave I
can't think of a more wonderful
relationship that any human being could
ever have than to be the slave of one
who loved and died for him who provided
everything he or she would ever need
through promises eternal protection
eternal blessing who raises that slave
to become a son adopts that slave into
his family and makes him a joint heir of
everything he possesses in the eternal
Kingdom so just taking the concept of
slave and turning it into some kind of a
pejorative thing misses the point that
there were lots of social constructs
some of the safest places people could
be in the ancient world would would be
with a master who loved them and cared
for them the Bible explicitly rejects
any mistreatment of slaves ever they are
to be treated with kindness and love in
a way that honors God and demonstrates
care for them now
that's very different that kind of thing
then
in supporting people across an ocean
putting them in Chains making them
basically nothing but an elevated animal
if even elevated that the Bible would
never tolerate but keep this in mind
there were probably 70 million slaves in
the Roman Empire during the life of
Jesus Jesus never tried to abolish
slavery if Jesus came to abolish slavery
he failed
if the Apostle Paul came to abolish
slavery he failed if the rest of the
Apostles agenda was to change the
culture knock off Caesar and wipe out
slavery they failed if that's true then
Jesus went to the cross and said it is
finished but it wasn't he didn't pull it
off but if he came to prevent us from
going to hell forever by bearing our
sins in his body on the cross then he
did accomplish his mission that was his
mission not to restructure the social
order of society there's that there's a
book in the New Testament called
Philemon and Paul writes this letter to
Philemon because finally even had a
slave named onesimus and he ran away so
he ends up in Rome and he runs into the
Apostle Paul and Paul tells him about
Christ then he becomes a brother in
Christ so Paul says go back go back to
Philemon and tell him you're his brother
and tell him you're sorry that you left
and make it right with him and he writes
this letter to Philemon and says take
him back contrary to abolishing slavery
Paul is saying go back and fulfill your
responsibilities to him as his brother
so slavery is just a social contract at
its best that it's worse it is the the
horrible kinds of thing that people sort
of depicted as today okay that's
unacceptable so let's talk about a
couple more of these issues because it's
I think edifying for folks and
informative the one obviously the
hot-button issues that have come up now
the big one obviously is Leviticus 18:22
which bothers the hell out of people the
same references in in the book of Romans
in the New Testament any reference that
has to do with the sin of homosexuality
obvious
is hot-button these days when to even
mention this in a biblical context
offends people to no end even in a free
society where religious people are not
forcing anything with regard to this
sort of behavior to even suggest that
certain behavior is sinful is
extraordinarily bothersome to folks how
do you defend that in a society where
Wiis where our general perspective is if
it's not an act that violates consent
then we haven't done anything wrong well
first of all let me say this the Bible
identifies both in the Old Testament and
in the New Testament homosexuality as a
sin clearly there's no getting around
that
that's the story of Sodom where you have
homosexuals in the city of Sodom trying
to attack angelic beings who are at the
house of lot that's why the term used to
be sodomite the Bible is clear on that
it's clear on that
in the Pentateuch about that kind of
behavior it's it's listed with things
like bestiality sex with animals the New
Testament affirms that but but I want a
hurry to say that's a sin but but that's
not some kind of sin that leads the
parade and is separated by light-years
from all other sins that is a sin to
which humanity is susceptible and some
people have more strong desires in that
in regard to that sin than other people
do for reasons that you know may be
psychological maybe part of their
history in their past it is a sin in the
New Testament the Apostle Paul says such
were some of you homosexual
effeminate and he says but you are
washed you are sanctified in Christ you
this is this is a very basic question
the whole purpose of the Christian
message is to confront the sinners sin
so you can call the sinner to repentance
and forgiveness the sinner doesn't like
that we had a question on the little
questionnaire that you your people sent
me it said do you feel like you might be
offending Democrats with some of the
things you say and my response to that
is look my goal is to offend everyone
that is my initial goal to tell you
that you are without God in the world
that there's only one Savior the Lord
Jesus Christ that you're in sin that sin
brings death and punishment but the good
news is Jesus Christ is the savior who
has provided a way for you to be
forgiven by burying your sins in his
body on the tree so that God's justice
is satisfied in his love can be extended
to you by putting your trust in Christ
so I I offend people all the time
because that's necessary if you try to
develop a kind of Christianity that's
inoffensive it's not Christianity it's
not the gospel so I'd be remiss if we
didn't actually talk about the
differences between Judaism and
Christianity because on so much of this
stuff we're on the same page considering
that legitimately half of the book is
the same but when it comes to the
distinctions between Judaism and
Christianity as a Jew whenever I hear
pastors speak about Christianity very
often I think to myself right all that
stuff's in the Old Testament so when
they say things like you know sin it has
to be cleansed by God right we have an
entire day yom kippur that is for that i
say three times a day a paragraph about
doing repentance before god plus an
additional section for repentance in the
morning prayers the idea of repenting
and confessing your sins before God is
something that is endemic to Judaism and
has been for for thousands of years the
idea that God is sovereign obviously the
two religions share philosophically
speaking put aside and putting aside the
the basic crux of belief in one story or
one historic incidence in your interview
if you if you put that aside what do you
think is the the key distinguishing
factor between the philosophy of
Christianity and the philosophy of
Judaism well first of all I don't like
to talk about it as a philosophy I'd
rather talk about it as a revelation
because it's divine so the same God who
wrote the Old Testament wrote the New
Testament that's my conviction the
scripture has one author and I need to
say this I am a Christian because of the
Old Testament without the Old Testament
I I don't
know whether I could believe the New
Testament and that may sound strange to
you but how do I know that Jesus is the
Messiah if I don't have all the
predictions of the Old Testament
defining him when he shows up for
example I wrote a book called the Gospel
according to God and it's from Isaiah 53
that great chapter and you read Isaiah
53 and it's it's the biography of the
Messiah the servant of the Lord and it's
it lays out his arrival and his
rejection and his death and his
resurrection and his ascension and is a
coronation it explains the gospel in
more specific terms than any chapter in
the New Testament he was wounded for our
transgressions he was bruised for our
iniquities the chastisement for our
peace fell on him and by his wounds we
are healed wow that sounds like the
Christian doctrine of justification
because that's exactly what it is and
then it says his life was cut off and
then it says he will see his offspring
well if his life was cut off how could
he see his offspring when I die I'm not
gonna see my offspring that's the
resurrection and then you have the
coronation you even have the in that
chapter a shift because the chapter
begins with the plural we you know he we
saw him and he was like a root out of
dry ground he was like a root sticking
up you trip over he was like a sucker
branch you whack it off he was
meaningless useless and there was no
beauty that we would desire him he
didn't fit our messianic picture and he
didn't do what we thought he would do he
didn't knock off the Romans and he
didn't set up the kingdom they he just
didn't fit our model and so we
considered him as nothing and the
language there they considered him as
non-existent and that's exactly what
happened because they completely
rejected him and the Romans took him as
a criminal to crucified him and then you
have this stunning reality in that
chapter it's like
stops and you hear this in the past
tense he was bruised for our iniquities
he was chastised for our peace whoa what
happened Zachariah says the day will
come when they look on him whom they've
pierced and mourn for him as an only Son
Wow
that's what they will say but that's
what the Jewish people will say when
they look on the one they pierced and
mourn for him as an only Son they'll say
we thought he was stricken by God what
we thought we were doing the work of God
in taking his life because it was a
blasphemer now we see he was wounded for
our transgressions he was bruised for
our iniquities and then says thakur i a
fountain of blessing is open to israel
and a fountain of salvation and then you
have that followed by the kingdom and
all the fulfillment of the old covenant
and all of it comes when Israel looks at
the Messiah and sees him for who he is
the interesting thing about Isaiah's
prophecy of that is he doesn't say it's
going to happen it's he doesn't use
future verbs he uses past verbs because
he's looking past Christ too when the
Jews look back on the past now we see it
now we see it and the New Testament Paul
says in Romans 11 all Israel will be
saved that is the purpose and plan of
God there is a Christian kind of popular
doctrine that I reject with all my heart
and that is that the church has replaced
Israel and the promises of God's called
supersessionism I don't believe in that
I think that honestly hate to say this
but I honestly think it is a latent form
of anti-semitism to say that I you you
can't tell me that God made promises in
the Old Testament to his people Israel
concerning his future Kingdom and
salvation and that he would give them a
heart a new heart and a new spirit and
he would write his laws in their heart
and they they would be saved and he
would be their King and they would be
his people and all those Kingdom
prophecies you can't possibly tell me
that God didn't mean what he said and
that that is one of the reasons I'm an
originalist it's very popular in
Christianity today to say the Old
Testament is interpreted by the New
Testament
that's not true because if that's the
case then nobody in the Old Testament
had any idea what was going on right
then you've got it that's not revelation
that's obfuscation well that's just a
pile of riddles other people say well
you have to you have to superimpose
Christ a christological hermeneutic over
every part of the old test that's not
true either
there's authorial intent I mean you're
an originalist when it comes to
constitutional things I'm an originalist
when it comes to the Word of God and I
know you would say that you feel more
comfortable probably in following a
rabbinical interpretation than you do
your own interpretation to some degree
I'm sure sure so you've removed the
authority one step from the one who said
the word of the Lord came to me and I
said this you're looking to this guy so
here's so here's the so here's the take
on rabbinical Judaism so rabbinical
Judaism in the in the Orthodox view I'm
sure you know this already but the
Orthodox view of rabbinic Judaism and
the Oral Law is that basically at the
time the the Torah was given there was a
understanding of what the Torah meant
that was orally transmitted to Moses and
there been a tradition is a part of that
so shot is so basically me handing off
authority to rabbis to interpret this
stuff doesn't alleviate me of my duty to
study which is why Jews over time have
been extraordinarily well educated
because we all study the Talmud we do it
daily we study the Torah we do it daily
we we are obligated at least three times
a week to read directly from the Bible
itself you know all of this the Jews
have been extremely literate over time
because we take the text very seriously
but with that said they're always and it
was an assumption that God had given a
text to human beings who are fallible
and live within the context of the time
in which they live meaning that if God
were to come down and then speak in
tongues to folks they wouldn't
understand so he has to give it to
people those people have interpretive
faculties God knows that which is why he
gave the Torah to people with
interpretive faculties so in other words
it's not me failing to go back and look
at the text of the Torah it's me
understanding that the text of the Torah
has been interpreted by people who have
spent more time with it than I am
or smarter than I am
and who have and who have you know spent
an enormous amount of time trying to
figure out exactly what the Torah means
in particular sections so for example
the example we use in Orthodox Judaism
most often is there's one commandment
that you're supposed to take this out
that you are supposed to guard the
Sabbath and keep it right uh the courts
of Shabbat you're supposed to remember
it in one section you'll see guard in
the other and the but there's no actual
Commandments as to what that means right
so what does it mean to keep this to the
Sabbath alright so unless you actually
have some sort of explanation of what
Sabbath is it could mean anything I mean
we could mean keep the teddy bear right
you have to actually have an
understanding of what the Sabbath is
which is where the Oral Law comes in so
me delegating out the interpretation of
that to people who are trying to boil
down what that meant at the time is a
form of originalism but it does
certainly have more of a common-law
aspect than the original ism of just
picking up a Bible and saying I
understand read it myself and understand
every permutation of it
yeah and I think that that's really a
good answer and I would say this as long
as you understand the Bible as
revelation intended to be understood
that you believe in the perspicuity of
Scripture in other words this is not
mysticism this is not fantasy this is
not some some kind of allegory that that
isn't inherent in what you're reading to
say for example as one rabbi I was
reading said that Abraham's consonants
in his name add up to 315 so that means
he has 315 servants well I mean come on
give me a break
no no I mean that kind of rabbinical
algorism which is all over the place so
all I'm saying is when Jesus came he
said the rabbi's have said this the
rabbis that you've heard it said you've
heard it said you've heard it said but I
say to you but I say to you but so he
was busy correcting what had developed
as very complicated matcha nations that
turned the Sabbath into a terrible
burden and he was salting that that to
the degree where he said you've
substituted the traditions of men for
the commandments of God here's a guy in
a ditch you don't go over and pick the
guy up out of the ditch because you're
trying to conform to these matcha
nations that have developed around it so
I just think that we when Jesus
confronted the crowds and particularly
the Jewish leaders he would say have you
not read have you not read he said it
over and over and over which is to say
that the Word of God can be understood
the Old Testament is revelation well
this is it this is why it's so
interesting because when I when I read
the New Testament myself and I obviously
not a believer in the divinity of Jesus
but when I see what Jesus actually has
to say about the Old Testament he seems
to be very similar to the stuff that
Zechariah is saying or that Jeremiah is
saying Jeremiah says that the the
sacrifices themselves are basically of
no use unless there's actual meaning
behind the sacrifices God wasn't there
because he likes the barbecue right it
actually has to have some meaning and
when Jesus comes along and he says
you're focusing in on all the details of
the Sabbath without actually recognizing
the rationale for the Sabbath and then
he exaggerated sit beyond the point it's
about you having God with all your heart
soul mind and strength right exactly and
then he even to make a point exaggerated
beyond the scope of what Jewish law
would permit so for example when he says
you're gonna leave a guy to die in a
ditch on the Sabbath that's against
Jewish law you can't do that you have to
violate the Sabbath in order to save a
life this is like basic black-letter
Jewish law but he's making a point which
is you guys are ignoring what's
important in order to focus in on the
mundane aspect of practice like that is
that's not unique to Jesus in other
words there's there's a long prophetic
tradition of people saying exactly that
and in the modern Jewish world that's
called Musser it's basically just
telling people what they should
understand about the values beyond the
beyond the black letter law and this is
why I think it's fascinating to me when
I talk with people who are real biblical
scholars in the from the Christian side
that all the errant say all a lot of the
areas where Christian scholars think
that Christianity has departed
dramatically from Judaism I think are
not really dramatic departures they seem
to be reflections of Judaism from a
slightly different angle even so far as
a lot of the stuff in the Sermon on the
Mount about you know love when when it
says that you're supposed to love that
brother as thyself and and you're
supposed to and you're supposed to treat
your brother as you would wish to be
treated and all of this I mean that's
that's present in the Old Testament - no
I think what Jesus did in the Sermon on
the Mount was elevate the teaching of
the rabbis elevated he went
but above them he said well you've been
told you shouldn't commit adultery I'm
telling you if you look at a woman to
lust after her you've committed a dollar
in your heart he got to the heart of the
law that they were content with the the
practical application of the law he was
not content with that
so I would say that Jesus was the purest
Jew that ever lived because he
understood the the elevation of the law
to the heart and the soul that it would
be a it would be a monstrous
responsibility for some committee to
have invented Jesus the you know when
you hear the even the people in his time
saying never a man spoke like this man
that he is a person that doesn't seem to
have been a product of human invention
and you could say well Jesus is a good
teacher but good teachers don't claim to
be God they don't say I and God are one
they don't say I created the universe
that that's not a good teacher that's
somebody who's crazy as a lunatic or
somebody who's trying to pull off a huge
deception so you you you cannot come to
Jesus and just patronize him as a noble
good Jewish teacher because he crossed a
line he crossed the severe line and the
Jews saw that either he's the Messiah
or he is a blasphemer and he needs to be
put to death and those are really the
choices you have so when you asked me to
show the the variation between Judaism
and Christianity morally no there's none
in in terms of God the same we don't
have the same God as Muslims Allah is
not the same God as Jehovah we don't
have the same gods as any other false
religion but we have the same God as
Jews and Christians he is the one true
creator God the one true Living God he
has a CD that is he is eternal by his
own nature he is uncreated the uncreated
one we believe he is he is more than one
person in one God that's why Genesis
says let us make man in our own image
and relationship comes from a God who
has relationship within himself but the
distinction between Christian
Judaism is what we do with Jesus Christ
the writer of Hebrews says if a
sacrifice had been enough to atone for
sin they would have stopped making them
but they never stopped morning and
evening morning and evening morning and
evening morning any you know basically a
priest was a butcher you have blood up
to his waist right maybe there is a
butcher he had blood up to his waist and
the frustration of it even on Yom Kippur
the Day of Atonement all the
bloodletting and year after year after
year after year this goes on this goes
on the Ghassan you have this most
amazing thing you come to the death of
Jesus Christ and at the death of Christ
the veil in the temple is rent from top
to bottom the Holy of Holies is thrown
open wow that's a statement from God
because it couldn't have been ripped by
men from the top down the way to God is
open there's no more barriers because a
suitable sacrifice has been found this
is the Lamb of God and amazingly soon
after that the whole sacrificial system
ends because that's the final sacrifice
and God validates that sacrifice by
raising him from the dead the
resurrection is a provable historical
fact so I think that's the issue it's
what do you do with Jesus that's the
issue of Christianity and I would just
say I have such a love for Israel I mean
all the people I love the most are
Jewish from Abraham you know to the to
the Apostle John who wrote the last book
in the Bible I have the same passion
that Paul had you could almost wish
himself a curse for Israel's sake
because they they have they have a
knowledge of God but but but they don't
know him because he can only be known
through Christ and that's the Christian
message
this is Judaism's culmination so I don't
see Judaism and Christianity as
antithetical I see them as perfectly
complementary so that what the Prophet
said the Messiah would be Jesus was that
fulfils it sacrificial system ends it's
never been reinstituted again the
one sacrifice the writer of Hebrews says
he perfected forever those that are
sanctified by his one offering he was
God's lamb a spotless lamb without
blemish God put on him the sins of us
all this is a stunning theological truth
because all the people who will ever
believe through human history their sins
are covered by Christ even those who
believe going back to Adam they're all
of them had to have a sacrifice that
paid the price for their sins whether it
happened before Christ their belief or
after Christ Christ is the focal point
so he bears in his body all the sins of
all who would ever believe through human
history this is a stunning thing to
think about God putting all the sin and
all the punishment on him people say
well how could one person bear that the
answer is because he's he's he's a
cosmic person he's he's an eternal being
he's he's vast beyond us with a capacity
to take that punishment so he gathers up
all the punishment for all the sins of
all the people because sin must be
punished God is holy and that frees God
satisfying his justice to offer grace to
all to believe in him I think that the
Jewish believers in the Old Testament
who were true believers in God and who
did repent were waiting for that
sacrifice knowing that no animal
sacrifice ever did it because they had
to go back and make another one and
another one another one
when is the one sacrifice going to come
and that's why that Isaiah 53 chapter is
so critical because that's the focal
point that's the focal point of Isaiah
by the way anyway
Isaiah interesting book 66 chapters like
the Bible the first 40 are judgment like
kind of like the Old Testament first the
thirty-nine like the Old Testament and
the twenty-seven New Testament are about
salvation the 27 chapters about
salvation the first nine are the the
salvation of Israel from nations around
it the back nine are the salvation of
the planet in the new heaven and the new
earth and the middle nine are the
salvation of people
individually and in the middle of the
middle nine you have Isaiah 53 it's
unbelievable what that book of Isaiah is
it's it pulls it all together and as you
narrow down and you end up with he was
wounded for our transgressions and this
becomes the confession of all who
believe in Christ
including one day Israel so I want to
say this to you personally you are a
testimony to the glory of God in man I
see the beauty of God's creation in you
I see I see the use of reason and
compassion and care I see so many things
in use so I don't I'm not denying that
reflection of God in you but I'm saying
you either believe Jesus is the savior
or you don't and that's the distinction
apart from that just this one
conversation with you
I could spend endless hours with you and
be the far richer for it but I would
always be saying the same thing well I
do have one final question for Pastor
John and that question is going to be
about the future of Christianity in the
United States whether you're optimistic
or pessimistic and what the church has
done wrong but for that answer you have
to be a daily wire subscriber subscribe
go to daily wire comm click subscribe
you can hear the end of our conversation
there pastor john macarthur i'm so glad
that you could come by i really
appreciate the time we need to go so
that you can take pictures of everyone
in the office because we have a huge
line out the door people who want to
take pictures with you it's really a
pleasure to have you and again you know
i mean in the fight for Western
civilization I'm gonna be fighting
shoulder-to-shoulder with you even if we
may part ways at the very end of the
book it's amazing to have you here and
again thank you so much for coming now
it's been my pleasure any time you would
ever want me to do it I'd love to do it
again with you sounds great thank you
Ben
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy Boren associate producer
Mathis Glover edited by Alex Singaram
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jess wah Oliveira and title
graphics by Cynthia and gula the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2018
[Music]